are sanctions working or not they are
working
right now they're helping Ukraine to
defend itself and hopefully to win the
war
longer term they will restrict the
growth of the Russian economy which will
in turn restrict Putin's ability to wage
more Wars making us all safer
whether we like it or not while he
remains in power we are back at Cold War
style containment
the sanctions should stay in place we
need to make sure they're enforced
because as Simon Says historically
they're evaded
and ideally we need to make them
stronger
Richard's The Economist here so I won't
go into detail on the sanctions
themselves or their economic effects but
in brief
the West's response to the invasion in
February was remarkably unexpectedly
strong and Swift and unified there was
near Universal condemnation in the UN
weapons started to be shipped
immediately and the first package of
sanctions was agreed and I think we're
now on to our sixth seventh package I've
lost count
they they were on a completely different
scale
from the smear slap on the wrist
in terms of sanctions that the West gave
Russia in 2014 after it initially
invaded the Don bass and Crimea
they cover hundreds of state-connected
individuals and entities who've had the
assets abroad Frozen doing business with
them is banned and they've been slapped
with travel bans that list is still
expanding
on the financial side all but essential
Financial transactions with a very small
number of Russian banks are banned
Russian banks are out of the Swift
International payment system credit
cards issued by Russian Banks don't work
abroad in addition the portion of
Russia's Foreign Exchange Reserve held
in central banks abroad has been frozen
and that makes up about half of the
total Russian Reserve
on trade export to Russia of a wide
range of goods sensitive ones and high
technology products in particular is
banned it includes micro microchips
vitally on the import side Europe is
dramatically cutting its purchases of
gas and oil on the gas there was
originally a rather vague plan never
laid out in detail to cut down on
purchases but Russia jumped the gun by
itself first turning off the Taps using
the need for maintenance of the of the
Nordstrom pipeline as an excuse and then
it actually sabotaged
extraordinarily the two Nordstrom
pipelines itself
so you're you're prevented from buying
more Russian gas willy-nilly
on oil the sanctions have not yet come
into Force they'll do that next month
from December the 5th
Imports of Russian seaborne Imports of
Russian crude will come to an end and
that will be extended in February to all
oil products
the G7 is putting together a price cap
on Russian oil the details of that have
not yet been announced but that will
come into a force also next month last
of all over a thousand Western firms
under pressure from customers in part
have voluntarily withdrawn from Russia
either closing or selling up completely
or mothballing operations
more firms have halted investment plans
so however this this message massive
package of sanctions have affected the
Russian economy so far
when they were first announced there was
when the war broke out there was Panic
shelves emptied ATMs more or less
stopped working the ruble crashed since
then things have stabilized but only
superficially shelves are full again but
with substitute more expensive Goods
inflation's running at nearly 13
rubles recovered but thanks to exchange
controls and the facts that Imports have
collapsed
on the all-important question of energy
prices they're coming down again the gas
prices coming down again after its spike
in the summer thanks to some rather
Nimble
um finding of alternative sources of
Supply by Europe and oil is down 287 a
barrel So Below the magic 100 a barrel
which is in normal times the the level
at which Russia can balance its budget
that's partly due to another fears of
another covert break outbreak in China
but also due to this imminent G7 price
cap
the Russian economy as a whole is
forecast to shrink by over three percent
this year over two percent next those
are disappointingly small figures but
they mask much bigger drops in sectors
dependent on Imports so high-tech
manufacturing telecoms Aviation
High-Speed Rail and vitally defense